i know it might not feel like it right
now
but it really is it's the only way to
make the bad mean something
bury it
bury it
pile good on top of good
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about ozark season 4 part 2. if you just
finished part 1 you probably have a lot
of questions and that's what i'll be
looking at in this video including when
can we expect the second half i'll be
getting into all the questions i had
after i made my part 1 video and
questions i got from you guys in the
comments there but i do have to give you
a quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched all of ozark through season 4
part 1 then this video won't be for you
and with that out of the way let's get
into it
so the biggest question everyone has is
when will part two come out the date
hasn't been announced yet but there's a
couple of things that we can look at
that will give us a good idea first they
filmed all 14 episodes at the same time
they broke them up into two parts
consisting of seven episodes each but
they don't have to go back into
production in between this means that
they'll probably do something similar to
what they did with money heist in its
final season they split that into two
parts and aired the second half three
months later doing that with ozark seems
likely and it's worth mentioning that
this is a netflix show that has won some
emmys in the past in order for this
season to be eligible this year all the
episodes would have to air by may 31st
so for a prediction i think it's safe to
say that it'll be coming out in 2022 i
think the end of april makes the most
sense and i would be surprised if it did
come out after that if it wasn't out by
the end of may i think after that finale
the next big question is what will
roost's next move be she knows the
cartel killed wyatt and darlene and she
does seem bent on going after javi after
jonah tipped her off for an average
person this would be a suicide mission
and even though it would be a mistake to
think of ruth as average it's still hard
to imagine how she'd be able to take him
out without serious repercussions and
they set her up to be in a place where
she's essentially lost everything so
that might not hold her back with hobby
having a deal with the fbi there are a
lot of interested parties including the
birds that don't want to see anything
happen to him i mentioned in my last
video i'm curious to see the differences
in how marty and wendy react to ruth
saying if you want to stop me you're
gonna have to kill me they made points
in part one to show that marty still
wants to protect ruth and the same can't
be said for wendy they have a shared
interest in wanting to stop her but
different feelings about ruth as a
person this is similar to their divide
over how to deal with jonah and marty
was to the point of saying that they
wouldn't stay together when they went
back to chicago in their argument over
that before he got the phone call about
taking navarro to meet with the fbi i
guess the one thing we can say for sure
is that ruth is going to do something i
don't think it's reasonable to think she
could be talked out of a response she's
low on allies though and frank jr is
really the only established character
that is around for her to turn to he
could take control of the kansas city
mob in his father's absence but they
also seem outmatched by the cartel so
ruth would have to come up with a pretty
impressive plan to utilize him and his
organization i think he will play a part
they certainly set him up to be on her
side but we'll have to wait and see what
that actually looks like there's also
the possibility that this new character
chuck might emerge as an ally she was a
friend of ruth's mom who she went to to
buy those seeds as a wedding gift for
wyatt and darlene i couldn't help but
think that they did a lot of work to
paint her as a compelling character if
that would turn out to be her only
appearance so i looked her up on imdb
and it has her listed for eight episodes
that website isn't always accurate but
this does lead me to believe that she'll
at least play a role in part two and
that seems like the makings of a pretty
good team up there's also another
interesting casting detail for part two
we're also going to be seeing hobby's
mother camilla alessandro she'll be
involved in the remaining episodes i
suppose if something did happen to him
then she could come looking for revenge
or may even have to take over the cartel
after what happened to navarro although
that deal with the fbi might just mean
that she steps in to advise her son with
her brother out of the way it's not
really clear what will happen with zeke
or the farm and both of those complicate
things technically zeke should just be
returned to child protective services
and he's not in the car with the birds
when they crash so it doesn't look like
he'll end up with them as far as we can
tell
as for the farm ruth was on the outs
with darlene which makes it hard to
imagine that she might gain control of
it three is still around and he was why
it's next to kin but he's not really a
main character at this point there is
potential for someone to fill that void
but who that might be doesn't seem clear
as far as i can tell the car crash that
the family has in the opening episode is
probably the thing i've seen people ask
about the most i do think this is a
flash forward to something that'll
happen in part two not a dream or some
other kind of trick and so to me it's
just a question on when does this happen
i think the implication is that it
happens at the end as they're just about
to get out of the ozarks for good but
the writers are using it to play with
our expectations i thought it was going
to happen in the part 1 finale right up
until it didn't it could happen earlier
and be the catalyst for a final descent
remember a car crash played a major role
in them going down this path in the
first place so that is something to
consider i've seen a lot of wild
speculation about this from ruth being
the one driving the truck to it being an
elaborate setup for them faking their
own deaths and none of them sound very
plausible however i do think there's
probably a twist of some sort
considering that they opened the season
with it that said what still kind of
stands out the most is that they're all
on the same page before it happens there
was a lot of family tension throughout
part one wendy is still not over what
happened with ben that's coming out in a
lot of different ways jonah is
definitely not over it he's using that
as a reason to rebel against his family
and marty and wendy are pretty much at
odds by the end of the season and yet
here they all are together and it looks
like they're getting out of town and i
suppose that is another big question
will the foundation be their ticket to
something different if anything was sort
of going in the right direction for the
family it was the work that wendy was
doing in setting that up of course
there's a cost that comes along with
that but if the fbi is taking over the
laundering for the cartel and they're
looking for offices to set up the
foundation in chicago then this has come
together as their escape plan i wondered
about the choice to show flashbacks to
season one with bruce his old partner
towards the end of part one those work
to show how marty has been changed by
the way things played out in the ozarks
it makes me wonder if wendy and jonah
will have something similar happen by
the time of the car accident outside of
the family we have a couple of wild
cards we have the private investigator
mel saddam considering that he's been
shown to be as competent as he is
annoying i think he has things figured
out as far as the bird's connection to
the cartel that would explain why he
contacted maya in the finale she'd be
our second wild card and based on what
we've seen so far it looks like mel will
add fuel to her i'm gonna do the job i
signed up for fire i refer to them as
wild cards because i'm not sure what
purpose they serve beyond complicating
things for the birds or i guess in
maya's case the birds and the federal
government that she works for they're
not the type of characters that would
pack an emotional punch if they got in
over their heads and were eliminated as
a result there might be more to what
motivates mel that we haven't seen yet
but i think he's mostly telling the
truth when he says he's there looking
for helen beyond them everything else is
just big picture questions will javi
just run the cartel in partnership with
the fbi will the bird family make it out
and run the foundation as a way to
launder their past will wendy and marty
stay married will the family all survive
should they all survive and then what
about ruth can she get herself out or
are we seeing an origin story about a
future boss of a brand new criminal
organization maybe after i've thought
about it some more i'll make a
predictions video but for now i think
that's a good place to leave things let
me know in the comments what you thought
about part one and how that sets up the
final part of ozark how do you think
this thing is gonna end please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon